bienvenidos de nuevo ahora estoy en el
problema 4 y para que vean que
considerados hoy con su tiempo
he decidido adelantar men y hacer esta
elegante gráfica para no desperdiciar su
valioso tiempo así que en esta gráfica
tenemos en el eje de las x el año de
nacimiento de lo que va a decir el
problema y aquí en el eje de las es el
número de niños y bueno el problema dice
la gráfica siguiente muestra cómo creció
la familia estrada entre los años 1991 y
1998 indicando la cantidad de niños que
tiene la familia al final de cada año en
uno de los años la señora estrada tuvo
que menos y bueno dijo la señora estrada
porque los gemelos no pudieron haber
nacido del señor estrada claro está pero
bueno en uno de dos años la señora
estrada tuvo gemelos en el mes de julio
en qué año nacieron los gemelos y bueno
para saber en qué año nacieron los
gemelos vamos a fijarnos en esta gráfica
y en esta gráfica aquí tengo el número
de niños y aquí tengo el año del
nacimiento como mencionaba hace
y si te das cuenta nosotros vamos a
poder saber cuántos niños nacieron en
cada uno de los años viendo cuánto
incrementa la gráfica de año en año esto
es muy importante y eso nos va a ayudar
bastante a resolver este problema y
bueno parece darte cuenta por ejemplo
que aquí en 1991 no tenemos ningún
nacimiento en 1991 no había nacido en
ninguno de los hijos de la familia
estrada al final del año hay cero niños
y por lo tanto hay cero nacimientos y
entonces podemos concluir que en 1991 no
tenemos ningún nacimiento muy bien ahora
vamos a fijarnos que pasó en 1992 en
1992 al final del año tengo un niño por
lo tanto algo tuvo que haber pasado de
1991 a 1992 para que tuviera ahora un
niño y lo que pasó es que hubo un
nacimiento en el año de 1992 para que yo
tenga en 1992 un niño pues tuvo que
haber nacido y por lo tanto aquí voy a
decir que en 1992 nació un hijo de la
familia estrada muy bien y qué pasa en
1993 si te das cuenta en 1993 al final
sigue habiendo un niño por lo tanto de
1992 a 1993 no cambia la cantidad de
hijos que tiene la familia estrada eso
quiere decir que en 1993 no tenemos
ningún nacimiento en 1993 no tenemos
ningún nacimiento por lo tanto voy a
poner x 0 nacimientos y poco a poco te
estás dando cuenta a qué me refiero
cuando nace un hijo de la familia
estrada lo que me estoy fijando es en
cuanto esté incrementando la gráfica por
ejemplo si no seguimos fijando nuestra
gráfica fíjate que quiere 994 cambio de
tener un niño a tener dos niños algo
pasó de 1993 a 1994 y lo que pasó es que
nació otro miembro más de esta familia
uno de los hijos de la familia estrada
nació en 1994 por lo tanto pasaron de
tener un niño a dos niños y si te das
cuenta para en 1995 ya tenían tres niños
al final de 1995 ya tenían tres niños
por lo tanto cambiamos de dos niños a
tres niños y aquí nació también otro de
sus hijos entonces aquí hubo otro
nacimiento y ahora vamos a ver qué es lo
que pasó en 1996
1996 a comparación de lo que pasó en
1995 se mantuvo igual por lo tanto aquí
no nació ninguno de sus hijos y en 1997
la familia estrada aumentó de tener tres
niños a tener cinco niños por lo tanto
en 1997 nacieron dos niños y en 1997
nacieron dos niños y en 1996 habíamos
quedado que no nació nadie aquí no nació
nadie en 1927 nacieron dos niños y en
1998 si te das cuenta se conservan de
1997 a 1998 no hubo un cambio en la
cantidad de niños que tenía la familia
estrada y bueno aquí cabe mencionar que
no hay que poner los dramáticos y por lo
tanto estamos contando en este problema
que ninguno de los hijos de la familia
estrada falleció porque si nosotros
pensamos que uno de los hijos murió en
estos años todo cambiaría pero bueno no
es un problema dramático y entonces en
no hubo nacimientos ahora lo que pasó en
este problema es que en uno de los años
la señora estrada tuvo que me los de
hecho en el mes de julio tuvo gemelos
el año tuvo gemelos la señora estrada y
bueno aquí ya está muy fácil la
respuesta la respuesta sería en 1997
porque es el único año tuvo dos hijos la
señora estrada por lo tanto la respuesta
sería en 1997 que por cierto en este
problema era el inciso de entonces mi
respuesta correcta es el inciso d
o no qué lástima borrar este problema
tanto trabajo que me costó y tan bonito
que me había quedado pero bueno todo sea
el nombre de la educación pues vamos a
quitarlo para seguir haciendo más
problemas de este libro así que borrar y
bueno ahora pongamos un nuevo pizarrón
perfecto así que sigamos vamos a
resolver ahora el problema 5 y el
problema 5 dice lo siguiente la media de
dos números xy es 5 la media aritmética
entonces déjame ponerlo aquí la media de
dos números de dos números equis y james
esto es igual a cinco y bueno esto sí lo
escribimos en matemáticas
x ma jin entre 2 es decir el promedio de
estos dos números esto es igual a 5 esta
es la media aritmética perfecto y además
me dice el problema que la media de x +
jay-z es igual a 8 vamos a escribir aquí
también la media pero ahora no solamente
x de james de x de james y de zeta esto
es igual a 8 y bueno eso como lo ponemos
en matemáticas que x + james + zeta
todos estos entre 3 esto tiene que ser
igual a 8 me estoy tomando el promedio
de estos tres números y esto tiene que
ser igual a 8 perfecto ya que sea estos
dos datos lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale z cuál es el valor que toma z y
bueno para responder esta pregunta lo
que quiero que te fijes es que aquí
tenemos dos ecuaciones y tres incógnitas
changos cómo resolvemos esto pero bueno
lo importante es no perder la calma y
tener en cuenta que se puede resolver
este
ejercicios y hay veces que no se ve esto
en el salón de clases si nosotros en
lugar de pensar en resolver para x para
ella y para zeta tal vez resolvamos de
esta primera ecuación para x + james de
nada nos serviría de aquí despejar a x o
despejar alguien porque cual nosotros
metamos tanto x hoy en esta ecuación me
quedaría una ecuación con dos incógnitas
por lo tanto mejor vamos a resolver esto
para x más bien vamos a despejar de aquí
a x medien y que tengo bueno yo sé que x
más bien esto dividido entre 2 es igual
a 5 pero como despejó de aquí hay que es
más bien pues lo que mostró es el 2
entonces si multiplico ambos lados de la
ecuación por 2 que me va a quedar que x
+ james esto es igual a 10 perfecto y
ahora que sé que x + i es igual a 10
pues porque era usamos esta información
y esta suma de x más lo puedo nombrar
como otra variable y esta variable lo
que voy a hacer es meterla en esta
ecuación voy a mantener esta información
aquí porque aquí tengo x + james y yo sé
que es más
10 por lo tanto esta ecuación de aquí
arriba la puedo escribir ahora como x
más bien pero x más vale 10 maceta entre
3 es igual a 8 vamos a ponerlo x mayer
pero x más hierba de 10 maceta
entre 3 esto es igual a 8 y de aquí si
te das cuenta solamente tengo una
incógnita y además una ecuación por lo
tanto puedo despejar de que hace está
que de hecho es justamente lo que quiero
lo que yo quiero es el valor de z
entonces creo que vamos bastante bien y
bueno para despejar aceta de aquí lo que
hubiese es pasar este 3 del otro lado
multiplicando y me va a quedar que 10
maceta esto es igual a 8 por 3 8 por 3
24 y ahora si yo restó 10 de ambos lados
de la ecuación me va a quedar que z es
igual a 24 - 1024 menos 10 es lo mismo
que 14 perfecto ya tengo el valor de z
que por cierto es el inciso b de este
ejercicio por lo tanto la respuesta
serían enciso vean y vamos a resolver el
siguiente problema así que déjenme
borrar otra vez esta pantalla y me va a
quedar esto perfecto muy bien manos a la
obra el problema 6 dice lo siguiente
bueno de hecho el problema 6 tiene dos
cuadros así es como un dibujo un
diagrama que nos sirve para resolver
este problema tiene un cuadrado muy
parecido a éste
otro también muy parecido a este y
después podemos hacer lo siguiente para
que el problema salga muy padre esto
tiene que estar de este color perfecto y
aquí adentro tiene que estar de este
otro color guapo esta sorprendente esto
de la tecnología me encanta muy bien
este era el problema
6 y el problema 6 lo que nos dice es que
tenemos dos cuadrados el primero tiene
del lado 5 entonces éste tiene de lado 5
cada uno de sus lados vale 5 y el otro
el que está adentro del cuadrado cuyo
lado es 5 tiene un lado de equis y lo
que nos preguntan es cuánto vale está
área sombreada que tenemos aquí así que
para resolver esto date cuenta que lo
que tenemos que hacer es una diferencia
de áreas tengo que ver cuánto vale el
área del cuadrado grande que es 25 5 x 5
25 ya estoy darle el área del cuadrado
que está de blanco que es el cuadrado
pequeño que es x x x lo cual me dan x
cuadrado justo esto es lo que vale el
área de lo que está sombreado el área
que me piden que por cierto esto es lo
mismo que el inciso en la respuesta es
el inciso iv y así de fácil y así de
sencillo estaba
problema así que déjame borrar otra vez
la pantalla y déjame ponerla de nuevo de
negro para resolver otro problema más
vamos a resolver el problema número 7 y
el problema número 7 me dice que la
multiplicación de cuatro variables r s t
y b de vaca esto tiene que ser igual a 1
y bueno esto por una parte porque
también me dan otro dato me dan que la
multiplicación de otras cuatro variables
las siguientes variables s t muy y bbva
que también esté muy be de vaca esto
tiene que ser igual a cero la
multiplicación de estas cuatro variables
es igual a cero y me dicen o me
preguntan cuál es el inciso correcto
cuál es el éxito verdadero entonces me
dan 5 inciso si los voy a apuntar aquí
el primero me dice que r tiene que ser
más pequeño que uno el segundo me dice
que ese es el que tiene que ser más
pequeño que uno así que vamos a ponerlo
aquí ese tiene que ser menor que uno
bueno el inciso se me dice que que es la
que tiene que ser más grande que un
medio la variable t tiene que ser mayor
que un medio y el inciso de me dice
el mundo tiene que ser igual a cero no
tiene que ser igual a cero y por último
a veces en el inciso n
me dicen que be be de vaca esa es la que
tiene que ser igual a cero ahora date
cuenta que nuestra primera expresión
tenemos cuatro variables multiplicándose
igual a uno y es justo por eso que
ninguna de estas variables puede ser
igual a cero porque entonces no me daría
de respuesta 1 esto quiere decir que
todas las variables tienen que ser
distintas a 0 y por lo tanto si alguna
de estas variables se repite aquí abajo
date cuenta que ninguna puede ser cero
entonces como este se repite y ese no
puede ser cero si te das cuenta ese
tiene que ser algo distinto de cero
porque si no arriba me quedaría igual a
cero lo mismo pasa contente está arriba
y por lo tanto te tampoco puede ser cero
y lo mismo pasa con b devaca b tampoco
puede ser cero lo que me queda que no es
igual a cero multita que ser cero para
que la expresión de abajo se cumpla y si
no es igual a cero estamos en el inciso
de así que nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo